let's talk about privacy for two minutes
because it's something that's kind of
comes up one of the things that we
certainly notice and we've talked about
is that you know the valley has a very
unique perspective on that it is a move
to the northeast there's a different
viewpoint there's an example I just want
to kind of start off with how many
foursquare friends and you got 9,000
okay 9000 go on and get on Twitter
130,000 right Facebook 1700 and then
11,000 on my public page so you're
living your life in public very much
your auto responders got your cell
number get you your home at hasn't run
hasn't yeah this is the this is the
weird side people are afraid of
they don't know yeah but once they know
it's like why didn't you know you get
really good come phone calls and if you
can spend call you hang up it's like
it's not that big a deal and I don't get
that much stuff at my email I should I
get far more span and intrusive kind of
things on the email that i doing that
people are unlikely to pick up the phone
after they receive that autoresponder
and satire abarai want to talk about
these kinds of thing dad it's something
about voice is like the only going to
call him if I have something surely
absolute saving with all of that kind of
living in public has it ever presented
kind of you ever feel like people are
crossing the line with you um not
because of that I can't walk around an
exhibit hall a tech conference it I get
it costed right and that has nothing to
do the fact that I checked in on
foursquare well they don't cost me
because I check in a Porsche merely
check in because oh there's Scoble and I
want to pitch him my brother a friend of
our sake but they're looking for you
once they see on Foursquare check-in
having this really the different you
know and personally if I'm checking in a
check on it I'm okay with it right I'm I
know what's going to happen yeah right
and you had that it doesn't happen if
people don't come out to where I am you
know they just see it's very weird
people are aren't aren't using these
tools really good
to that level starts talking a lot about
it but I think it's paranoia yeah I I
can see the fear and I I'm actually
worried about other things so if we all
live in public and I can watch you all
day long now I can see patterns in your
life that you might not even know exist
and the credit card I talked with
somebody works at beads anything he says
well he says they can predict somebody's
going to get a divorce a year before
their come on how because their spending
habits changing and you can start doing
things with your money to protect
yourself against impending bad events
here mm-hmm and so if and the CIA is
doing this right how did they catch
terrorists they looking for patterns
mm-hmm and if you have enough data and
have enough people passing information
back in but you can see those pattern
you know if if a rackspace executive
keeps flying to a certain company and
keeps go visiting there you can start
saying that guy's making a business deal
or being acquired or something like that
by changing companies or change the
happenings right so now now you start
calling all his friends at work and go
why does he always visiting amazon or
what you know and wow we didn't have
that pattern before you know you that
was opaque to us now and now it could be
very visible right and so we're going to
have different privacy concerns in the
future whoo-hoo then we have to you know
it's a little weird for old people to
put the stated right because it's like
we didn't put our medical history up we
don't talk about that you know Steve
Jobs didn't want to share his kidney
problem or the liver problem right but
in the future you gonna put that up on
your blog so that the best doctor in the
world is going to cook them see that or
somebody who has the same problem as you
and says hey I did the research and
here's the best doctor and here's them
the news medical science and here's the
drug you know you better check this out
and ask your doctor about the stuff you
know mm-hmm as true I interviewed a
surgeon he said the knowledge and
medical stuff is changing so fast you
can't
he's a Stanford you know a long surgeon
who is like one of the best in the world
and he can't he says everything he
learned in medical school is completely
obsolete 30 years ago right and so now
he uses an iphone to keep track of
what's going on in the world you know so
and he looks up your symptoms on the
iphone to make sure that the science
didn't change the last 24 hours because
some some doctor and Harvard you know
we're somewhere else in the world just
you know discovered a new treatment or
discovered a new you know way to deal
with this yeah i mean i just started
mountain biking you know and i have a
cycle meaner i think himself i use i'm
trying out a bunch of different ones but
it's a calendar there's a map and a
calendar with a bunch of information and
how fast i was coming right oh it's
great and you know so you shared a nice
but yeah it's so good at fixing it
because it you know while you're writing
it cuz it tells facebook Scoble just
started a ride right and then it goes
into facebook and my friends comment on
facebook and say oh great jobs double
you're exercising phone and it leaves
those condos connolly while you're a
buyer while i'm on come on for real for
real Wow and lets you know and it's
making a map so every five minutes they
get to see how far I'm right I can urge
me not go further man it's awesome don't
puss out yet you know that is cool it's
called and so when you add mobile and
location everything it changes it
changes what you know what we can and
social